here the point of this is to do two
things number one give you another
motivation for white chambers awesome
and also remind you of what this whole
exercise
this whole activity is about so just put
your pens down and watch
it will be more valuable to
watch person take that sound later
you'll have time
so
what motivated chain rule in the first
place okay or what motivated our us
looking at and thinking we need a better
tool okay and the reason why is when we
had a look at this we thought this this
is just ridiculous i mean we could
extend it i suppose if you had a lot of
time and then you could just go term by
term and you could differentiate but we
thought just why waste time surely
there's got to be a better way okay so
that's what we saw here
when you look at something like this
this is going the other way this is not
like
arbitrarily more complicated this is
actually a very very simple graph but
you encounter more or less the exact
same problem right which is that well
you know it's not quite impractical to
expand
it's impossible to expand you just can't
do anything to it it's as simple as it
gets okay but you can see despite being
such a different kind of problem chain
rule is still exactly what we need to
use here right
how should we rewrite this the square
root of 4 minus x in order to make it
clear what we need to do
very good so
what you've got here is this power okay
and once you've done this this is a
beautiful thing about how like when i
say powerful
chain rule is powerful because it just
takes such a variety of different things
and just make mint speed of them okay
i'm gonna do what i said before
i'm gonna say well this is why
i'm not gonna do my substitution i'm
just gonna do the inside and then i'm
going to do the outside okay inside then
outside so let's have a go at this
when i do the inside the derivative of
the inside is 4 minus x
sorry the inside is 4 minus x so the
derivative of the inside is
just minus one but four contributes
nothing just look at this coefficient
minus one there go okay
now then i now think i have the outside
to deal with that's something to the
power of a half we just use our power
rule right we bring the coefficient
sorry the power out the front to be the
coefficient and we reduce the power by
one
so the power here is a half right so the
half comes out the front
okay and then what gets gets left in
here the power reduces by one it's the
same thing we've been doing with all our
powers
so i've done the differentiation now i
just want to tidy it up a little bit
being that it was not given it to me in
index form i don't really want to give
it back in index form if it's at all
possible so what am i going to do with
this thing
this really here with the negative it
means go down the bottom of a fraction
right you change the sign you cross the
line okay so that's going to come with
the 2. i've got a minus 1 over
that 2 is down there with the square
root for minus x okay now let's think
about this thing right you could just
stop and you can say well i'm done i'm
finished i i've got the derivative happy
time okay let's just go another step
further because the whole point of like
me saying
we're not just monthly applying rules
what is the derivative what does the
derivative tell us what's the point of
the derivative
it's the gradient function right now
you look at this thing what does this
look like okay what does this look like
um you know it's going to be half of a
sideways parabola okay but not only that
it's not the square root of x
it's not even the square root of x minus
4 it's 4 minus x so what's happened to
that
what effect does that have it's gone
that way right it's flipped horizontally
because the minus sign is applied to the
x which is a horizontal thing the minus
sign of course is over here or here
it'll be on the y so it would be
flipping this way right
okay so therefore what does this look
like this is the shape
okay
intercept here
four
intercept here two okay that's all you
need to do it's finished okay what does
this thing tell us what does this thing
tell us it's beautiful look
this square root on the bottom okay
square roots are always positive by
definition okay
that's positive that's positive that's
negative so without even graphing it
without any getting close to graphene
you know the entire derivative
is negative right of course it's
negative look it's decreasing right not
only that where is the derivative
defined
what is the derivative defined
it's defined for x
is less than
not inclusive
because it's on the denominator right
less than not inclusive of four correct
x is less than four okay
what's this thing look like unlike this
which has no no denominator okay this
guy has an asymptote right there
okay can you see why just have an
asymptote